good morning everyone and Wow if you
could stand here and look out at this
what a sight and and what an amazing
thing to have all of you show up and to
spend this time with us here today we
have a fantastic day lined up for you
lots to update you about but also this
is a time for us to get together meet
each other share ideas and have a bit of
fun we are a community after all and
it's the spirit of community that I've
come to look forward to with these play
time events we did our first play time
event about four years ago back in
California since then we've taken this
on the road 32 events in 14 countries
all over the world it's been a great
opportunity to connect with our
developers in the Mar in in many many
markets around the world and I'm very
pleased to say that today with you here
in Berlin this is our biggest play time
event ever so thank you
we know that you're all busy people a
lot of you traveled to be here took time
out of your regular routines we're so
grateful to be able to spend this time
with you because we really all are on an
amazing journey together tomorrow
actually is the 9th anniversary of the
first launch of the very first Android
smartphone extra credit for any of you
who know what know who know what phone
that was and where it launched no fair
using Google for that by the way nine
years that means that everything about
this world of smartphones as we know it
has happened in less than 10 years this
Android community that we have that now
reaches more than two billion devices
all over the world is less than ten
years old
it's amazing to think about the
innovation that's happened during that
time how networks have gotten faster how
devices have become these powerful
computers in our pockets and how screens
on your wrist and in your car and in
your home have gotten smart and
connected and we've been blown away with
each of these waves of innovation we've
been blown away by the work that you all
have done to bring these devices to life
so
we we feel and at Google Play itself is
just over five years old and that's
amazing to think about we're now
delivering more than eight billion
installs every month on play reaching
users all over the world these are apps
that entertain us and educate us inform
us keep us healthy help us get things
done in our lives and we take very
seriously the responsibility to make
Android and play a rewarding platform
for all of you here in the AMIA region
we have users of all types we have very
tech forward power users probably like a
lot of us in this room we have families
who use their smartphones to stay
connected with each other and share
their experiences and we have users who
are being introduced to smartphones in
computing for the very first time in
countries where the infrastructure and
networks can barely support them our job
as a platform is to help you build the
products you want to build reach the
audience you want to reach sometimes
reach audiences you didn't even know you
had we take that job very seriously
we're investing heavily in tools to help
you build apps on Android distribute
them in Google Play we're investing in
one of the largest billing and payment
platforms on the planet and we're
constantly looking for ways to apply
Google's technology to the consumer
experience on Play for example we've
matched our human curation with Google
machine learning technology to help
match the right app to the right user in
the right context and in a lot of case
in some of these cases these investments
are happening right here in Europe for
example our team that builds the play
console which I know many of you use and
our play publishing tools is based in
London and of course our partnership
teams and our support teams that
work with you are based here in the
region and we have teams that work with
mobile operators and Android device
manufacturers in the region to complete
the picture of our ecosystem
thanks to those teams by the way we're
now connected with 90 mobile carriers in
38 countries in amia for for billing
which means that more than 400 million
users in the region can pay for their
purchases on Google Play through their
mobile phone bill it's really valuable
to have these teams here to be able to
interact with you regularly not just at
events like this so we can learn how to
serve you better and it's been amazing
to see the progress that developers in
this region have been making apps and
games developed here in amia are now
generating two and a half billion
downloads per month globally on Google
Play
that's amazing revenue growth from apps
and games developed here in amia is
accelerating the number of developers
grossing more than a million dollars a
month through their apps developers
based here in amia that number has grown
30% this year alone that's phenomenal
progress congratulations
going forward we have we're working on a
lot of things to make our platforms more
powerful and more intelligent to help
you build better and more performant
apps reach broader audiences better
engage your users and better understand
your users and you'll hear a lot about
those things today I'm also really
excited about the innovation that we're
seeing in devices which is a function of
the power of the Android platform
coupled with great work being done by
our device manufacturers and this
innovation is happening in targeted ways
in every segment we've seen some
phenomenal Android flagship devices come
out this year these are devices that
really are pushing the boundaries of
technology and computing and industrial
design and those devices will bring us
new opportunities next year for example
what will we be able to do when devices
include onboard
artificial intelligence processing
capability or when devices include
capability to build AR apps to bring the
real world into your apps and vice versa
and in the mid tier segment we've seen
manufacturers be able to deliver premium
hardware at affordable prices which is
going to engage an entirely new segment
of users in a much deeper way with apps
and at the entry level we've seen
innovation in data plan pricing and the
ability to bring very low cost quality
smartphones to users and markets around
the world and make computing more
accessible than it's ever been before
our own project go which we talked about
at Google i/o is aimed at this segment
and aimed at working on both better
devices at lower cost but also a set of
best practices for all of you to reach
users in these markets and create unique
experiences for them I'm also excited
without by all the ways that Android is
coming to more types of devices with
Android wear and Android auto and
Android TV and now on the desktop with
Android apps available on Chromebooks
not only is this creating opportunities
to build specific use cases for these
devices but it's also making us think
about a world in which users have
several of these devices and are moving
across these devices during their days
and how can we create experiences that
bring these devices together and bring
these experiences together all of this
represents our opportunity going forward
and it's also going to challenge us to
keep up but as a community I think we're
up to the task and I can't wait to see
what we all do next so thank you and
with that I'll pass it off to ish on to
talk about the Play Store thank you
thanks Jimmy hi everyone my name is Ian
and I focus on Google please business
across apps games movies TV and the
other content verticals in amia I am
really excited to tell you about all the
changes that we're making in the store
to make it the best possible destination
for users to engage with your apps and
games now as Jamie said plays mission is
to bring devices to life on mobile and
beyond so whether it's your phone your
watch or increasingly your car play is
the thread that connects those two
billion devices to the content that
makes those devices magical and that's
why I'm really keen to share with you
some of the improvements that we're
making on personalization which is the
building block of everything that we do
on Play and I'm also going to talk a
little bit about the new experiences
that we're creating in the store so
let's dive straight in with
personalization we have created a new
taxonomy that groups apps and games into
hundreds of different topics that users
can engage with this taxonomy drives our
search filters as well as the
recommendations on the home page we also
want to go beyond the install and focus
on reengagement now you'll see a lot of
changes that we're making in the store
but one good example of that is that
don't forget to try a cluster that
surfaces apps and games that you've
recently installed now personalization
and machine learning are great tools to
connect up the right content to the
right user you heard Jamie mentioned
that just now but in the store we want
to do more we want to help users decide
what content to actually install by
highlighting the very best of the
catalog and that's why creating new
editorial experiences has been a big
focus area for us this year including
rich long-form content that you see up
there
which explains why we've selected to
highlight that particular app
these editors choice stories are now
available in 17 different countries in
addition to that we're continuing to
invest in a number of different programs
that reward and recognize our developer
partners for creating wonderful
experiences on Android and play such as
the Android excellence program and the
best of play and in that vein it gives
me great pleasure to announce the launch
of the second edition of the Google Play
indie games contest in amia yes thank
you this this contest aims to celebrate
to recognize and reward the very best of
the indie games talent that we have in
the region finalists will be showcased
in the indie games corner of the Play
Store they'll get a chance to showcase
their games at the Saatchi Gallery in
London as well as been a number of
different prizes that will help them be
successful on Android and play now we're
really lucky today because we have a
number of finalists from last year's
contest in the audience with us so I'd
like to take a minute to actually ask
all of them to please stand up there we
go can we have a round of applause for
them please
so if any of you have questions about
what that experience was like please
reach out to them in the break for a
chat all the details about this year's
contest are at the playground which is
right below us
and that's where you can sign up as well
so please do all right moving on from
indie games to all games now apps are
different from games and we all know
that so we have elevated games to its
own destination within the store not
only does that drive more users to
gaming content it also gives us the
chance an opportunity to create new
experiences that are unique to gaming
such as immersive recommendations that
include trailers or screenshots of
actual gameplay we also want to give
users more control of how they explore
the catalogue so we're experimenting
with new formats in the store such as a
section dedicated to new games that
highlight the latest high quality
releases on play similarly we've
launched a new section of premium
section on the store that highlights our
paid games only and also showcases
content that is on sale using our
strikethrough pricing feature this this
collection went live last month and
we've already seen a big increase in
engagement as well as in purchases we
also want to be known as a store where
gamers can discover what's happening on
games that they already have so a first
step to live Ops discovery is through
the use of the live ops guard that
focuses on major in-game events that are
happening now on the games that users
are currently playing now that's a lot
about games so now moving on to apps as
you'll see in the middle screenshot
we've already started to feature a major
content events in the entertainment
category and we're going to be extending
that to many other categories going
forward
and finally I'm really excited to
announce the launch of our very first
integration with Android instant apps
which now comes with a try Now button
which are directly on the store listings
page that allows users
to experience some of the functionality
of the app without actually having to
download it that was a really quick
Whistlestop tour through some of the
changes that we're making in the store
and to tell you more about some of the
changes we're making of the play console
I'd now like to hand over to Coby Thank
You thanks Ishaan
hi I'm Coby a product manager on Google
Play the play console offer you tools at
every step of your app lifecycle last
year we had a big focus on quality we
launched Android virals at i/o the play
console is where you release your app to
users and we keep on iterating our
testing targeting and release tools
based on your feedback
finally the console offered tools to
everyone on your team marketing and
acquisition financials customer support
everyone can find tools that are helpful
for what they do let's start with
quality you're probably familiar with
this slide fifty percent of one star
reviews are when users complain about
bugs or stability a higher quality apps
means happier users which drives all
your KPIs up revenue retention you name
it it's the foundation of your whole app
success and what we give you with
quality is the combination of metrics
tools and rewards for metrics we collect
telemetry data from the field and
surface it to you through Android vitals
we offer you tools before during and
after a release before the release we
offer you the pre-launch report and we
recently added some features in this
report allowing you to get it for every
alpha and beta apk that you have during
your release we offer you their release
dashboard which shows you the health of
your release comparing to previous
releases and after the release we offer
you android vitals
finally we Google Play rewards apps that
show exemplary behavior
so we launched Android vinyls at i/o and
you started using it right away in the
last 28 days we've seen 65% of top
developers using Android vials with
vitals everyone on your team not just
engineering can set KPIs
around up quality and I'm happy to
announce that today we're launching five
new bad behaviors in Android vials for
example on the stability front will now
show you sessions when there are
multiple crashes and on the battery
front we will let you know when your app
drains unnecessary power when the user
is away from their device leading to
unnecessary drain we've also revamped
the Android viols dashboard to begin
with will significantly encourage the
device coverage we work with OEM to add
flagship and devices all the way to
mid-range bestsellers so you now have
much more data at your fingertips the
Android Valls dashboard itself was
changed to show your performance
overview at a glance including
performance over time and benchmarks and
Android vials plays now a key signal in
Google Play are search and discovery
algorithms favor apps with better vitals
and when your app is considered for
promotional opportunities like new and
updated editor's choice or Google Play
Awards
vitals play a key role an area that is
related to quality and is near and dear
to our heart is security so I'm happy to
announce a new program the Google Play
security reward program how does it work
so firstly we'll be reaching out to
developers like you asking you to opt in
and join the program then we'll have
friendly security researches scan your
app and if they find a security
vulnerability they report it to you
through your bug reporting system if you
don't have one our friends from hacker
one will be happy to help then once you
fix the vulnerability the researcher
comes back to Google for a payout then
our Android security team can scan the
entire catalog surfacing thus a
vulnerability to other developers
helping them fix their app making the
Android ecosystem more so
here for our users together with other
security programs we have in Google
Android and Chrome we're happy to
continue our great relationship with the
security industry making the app
ecosystem safer okay let's talk about
releases now and I have some exciting
news here you know for years beta
testing has been one of the most popular
features on Google Play we have more
than 300,000 developers using beta
testing but one feature request that
always emerged was the ability to target
apps and betas to different countries
and you can see the feedback here from
our friends at space ape games telling
house how badly they want this feature
so I have some great news starting today
we're launching this feature you'll now
be able to target your beta apps to
different countries
so you know until today the way it works
is that when you target the country
let's say Germany you have to target it
across alpha beta in production but
starting today you will be able to
target your app to different countries
in alpha versus beta versus production
so for example you can run a beta test
in Germany before launching it publicly
we're sure you'll find great ways to use
this new feature another feature that
you guys use quite a lot is staged
rollout and I have another great
announcement here in a few weeks we will
start allowing you to do country
targeted staged rollouts how does it
work you can see right here let's say
you have an issue you want to isolate
let's say in India so you start by
rolling at your app to 1% India only if
everything looks good then you can
continue and go to 10% in India only at
that stage perhaps you want to add a
control group country maybe you add
Indonesia still at 10% then if
everything looks good then you bump to
20% and add more countries and finally
you finish by rolling out to 100%
globally pretty cool right
another feature we launched at i/o is
the device catalog it allows you to look
at the hardware spec of every device
supported by wrap it became very popular
with you guys
for example in the last 28 days we've
seen 66 percent of top developers
engaging with the catalog and one thing
the Kellogg allows you to do is to
search for devices based on a range of
attributes a cram system-on-chip
screen size and density and many more
starting today we're launching a new
feature allowing you to construct those
search queries save them and reuse them
across your catalog so you can create a
search query like high screen devices
running Android oh and then use it in
every app in your catalog to see the
installs rating and revenue driven by
those devices another feature we're
launching today comes to answer a very
frequent question we get from you guys
why isn't this device supporting my app
so starting today you'll be able to go
to every device in the catalog
deep dive to that device and see the
support status across alpha beta and
production for example highlighting
cases like the one you see right here
where the device doesn't support your
app because your app requires certain
hardware or software feature that this
device doesn't support now I want to
continue and talk about how we help you
grow your business and I want to focus
on the fastest growing business model in
the industry subscription you remember
that at i/o we shared that the number of
subscribers and the revenue from
subscription businesses have doubled on
Google Play in the last year alone and
I'm going to share with you some new
features at every step of the process
setting up subscriptions acquiring new
users and retaining them so let's start
with setup we recently launched the Play
billing library 1.0 1.0 and using this
library is a great way to make sure
you're using the latest and greatest
features are in a billing stack has to
offer in a few days we'll be launching
another big improvement to testing we'll
be launching a good form of payment and
a bad form of payment associated with
every test account this allows you to
test both the happy path and the unhappy
path without actually using a real form
of payment and in addition we're
launching a new subscription management
page in the Play console today that
allows you to opt in into various
features related to subscriptions now
your app success depends on your ability
to acquire new users and our data shows
that 78% of users start with a free
experience so in making some changes to
how free trials work on Google Play to
begin with to reduce free trial abuse
will be making free trial and app level
setting in addition we've heard your
feedback about wanting a shorter free
trial period so starting starting last
week we now allow you to run 3 trials of
minimum 3 days and user acquisition is
important but if you cannot retain those
users you have a problem right so we're
here to help you remember that at i/o we
announced that we have a feature called
account hold that is available on beta
so I'm happy to announce that starting
today this feature is available
all of you all you need to do is opt-in
through the new subscription page in the
play console but the one feature I'm
really excited about is our new feature
for win back we will now starting today
we will notify you every time the
subscription state changes including
cancellation in real time this means
that no more waiting until the end of
the month
to find out that the subscriber earned
two weeks ago we will now let you know
in real time allowing you to start the
wind back process right away and in
addition we're enabling another new
feature today subscription restoration
this feature allows users on Play Store
to come back to your service if they
change their mind without almost any
friction so today we shared some
exciting news we have new android vitals
we have country targeting for alpha and
beta and we have some great new features
to drive the success of your
subscription businesses we're sure you
use those features to do what you do so
well is launching such great apps and
games on Google Play thank you very much
for joining and enjoy playtime
[Applause]
you